this is a production of Cornell
University
my name is Johannes lemon I teach salty
nutrient management at Cornell
University I'm very excited to get
together with all of you and and
maintain the the dynamics and an
enthusiasm around soil health and take
forward want to give a shout out to to
my team of course a lot of the research
lesson on the young ones growing
generation of professional in this area
and and provide enormous to the story of
Agriculture maybe some of the dark side
that causes some issues in nutrient
management as nutrients and other
substances such as hormones antibiotics
other endocrine disrupters are coming
into our soils and from there into the
water so that we are faced with
eutrophication and other ecosystem
service losses including no swimming for
students in the summer in Cayuga Lake
which is a big problem so we we are
looking at ways of innovative ways to to
bring waste to value and one of these
approaches thermochemical approach is
pyrolysis where we can show together
with a company in Rochester and a
professional knows I'll make her for
Venus grows and and homeowners moment hi
mark and that we can indeed transform a
problematic ways such as dairy manure
very wet waste into a marketable
substance for greenhouse growers that
has a relatively hard large value
already in in the solids we came up as a
replacement value for close to two
thousand dollars per ton of of material
of dairy manure material that otherwise
otherwise would have a negative cost aka
a social and environmental and
commercial cost and burden we we want to
take that forward because many of the
waste Barry is one other animal wastes
are others
but there are a lot of different ways
that are are in our food system some of
them are in rural environments some of
them are point sources in industrial
food processing here is one of them so
we're talking with uh noisy Bush about
their waists and and seeing how we can
recycle them and find ways to recycle
nitrogen which is a huge problem in this
respect we are discovering that we can
actually strip nitrogen out of liquid
phases and precipitate them find them on
carbonaceous surfaces and that's that's
very new science that shows that we can
make carbonaceous material that actually
has as much nitrogen up eighteen percent
nitrogen we're getting into the area of
a commercial nitrogen fertilizer we are
trying to find innovative ways to
utilize carbon dioxide to coat animal
manure carbonaceous material with co2
functional groups that then capture more
ammonia gas so we're trying to figure
out ways of recycling solids as well as
nitrogen in the gas phase that would
have application for both their industry
but also the poultry industry where we
know we have a lot of nitrogen pollution
aerial nitrogen pollution that then
finds its way in waterways and and and
ends up causing problems in water
resources we are have recently opened a
process facility that works at scale and
are now ready to work with industry both
farmers at the end of using materials as
a soil amendment to recycle nutrients
and and carbon as well as industry that
have waste both on farm and the food
industry in the middle as large
producers and we welcome discussions
about that and are open for your wastes
thank you very much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu